happy New Year gang we are kicking the
year off right doing the live stream
tomorrow evening New Year's Day come
hang out with the boys yeah we got a lot
planned we got interviews with Patty we
got interviews with Denise we're giving
away a goddamn Cruise ladies and
gentlemen if you join this stream we're
going to be giving away a cruise to
someone in the Stream it's gonna be a
good time we got signature cocktails we
got guests coming by go to moment.co.yg
the Link's in the description sign up
today save a couple bucks let's do it
so another
edition of are you garbage the show
where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley hey everybody out
there and welcome back to everybody's
favorite new podcast this is are you
garbage oh yeah it's that little show we
sit there with your favorite comedians
and we find it at the group to be classy
yeah those are just a big old piece of
trash I'm your host James Foley coming
at you on a beautiful day we're down
here in antuti's basement she's upstairs
getting ready for the New Year's Eve
festivities okay okay she just picked up
a bunch of those funny glasses that say
the uh the year on them 2019.
all right [ __ ] all right Carlos is
coming at you across the table
what the [ __ ] I was just kind of weak
and he comes at me like this
ah it's like you saw that one coming huh
yeah anybody did it here's the CEO of
are you garbage he's an international
businessman and he's my best pal the
whole world unfortunately Give It Up
it's Kevin James Ryan everybody come on
Chris and his kid what's up everybody
for a cruise
thanks for tuning in uh as always please
make sure you rate if you subscribe on
iTunes full video of album YouTube as
you know those numbers are up again and
obviously you want to talk about really
cooking hachimachi patreon.com are you
garbage sign up join that [ __ ]
contingent of the army of garbage good
time over there okay yeah good time we
got a lot of Vlog stuff we gotta [ __ ]
you get a weekly episodes of hard
feelings weekly episodes of ayg it's a
good [ __ ] time and then also I'd be
remissed if I didn't mention this is
coming out on the Eve it is of the big
live stream you're getting this a day
early early release early release you're
getting this on Saturday the day before
the live stream gotta make room on the
shelves for the live stream Everything
Must Go Daddy-o
um we are doing our live stream live
from Toadies it's going to be at
moment.co
ayg sign up today if you're the day
you're hearing us and you save a couple
of bucks yeah you saved two three bucks
sign up we got guests coming we got
Patty and Denise interviews cocktails we
got cocktails we could do answering some
questions from the chat from the patreon
a whole nine yards get [ __ ] involved
and we're giving away
in my head I'm like I know there's
something else and Foley's like
cocktails I'm like yeah that's what it
was we're giving away goddamn Cruise
because everybody loves them everybody
wants a cruise now you got yourself a
[ __ ] Cruise so when you join the live
stream it's got to be live you got to
join live terms and conditions apply you
join live
um yeah people were asking if I watch it
later in the week
can I still win like what are you
talking about yeah also Tony's got a
[ __ ] time machine we go back in time
and pull your name buried in shrimp
tails by then what do you mean
um so yeah we're giving away uh
something we gotta figure that out we
haven't really talked about it only that
we're giving away a cruise for two I
assume it'll be the same package you
gave me not the exact pack of course I
told you I did a lot of research on it
and what I did the October is the best
time to go wow other than that the
monetary value that I that I put in the
gift card will cover uh a three-day
cruise uh from the from Miami to the
Bahamas Now if you're on the Left Coast
or well there's different ports all over
the place but different ports of call
what we could do is just do a thousand
dollar gift card
to any Cruise the cruise line of your
choice cruise line of your choice there
it is we're figuring it out in real time
all right and enjoy if you enjoy the
lives we're not just sending a grand
because you'll use it on drugs
uh we want you to go on the cruise yeah
non-transferable no no no selling this
thing for 50 cents on the dollar hey how
are you doing yeah it's a gift that I'd
respect
a couple of couple of [ __ ] points my
way you want to get your neighbors out
of their house for three days so you can
root through their underwear drawer
there you go sniffing some panties let's
do it and boxers that's how I do yeah uh
yeah so check it out be a good time we
got a lot [ __ ] planned we put a lot
of effort and money into this thing to
make it cool and make it exciting and
make it a fun time so it's gonna be fun
yeah and tickets are still on sale for
the February 3rd show of The Gramercy
theater but they're starting to move a
little bit it's more than halfway gone
yeah so get those that's gonna go so
that's gonna go don't don't sit around
on that if you're in the city come see
us we love you thank you for everything
what a great year you guys are fantastic
and how about a nice quick shout out to
our producer extraordinaire the magic
man makes us all look good works the
ones and twos crosses the t's and dots
the eyes give it up for T-Bone
mcgruffins Toby McMullen everybody hey
what's up dudes what up T-Bone and
there's something else I keep forgetting
what's your middle name again Benjamin
Benjamin is it really what it is it
being honest yes wait you're [ __ ]
with me loser Benjamin correct Benjamin
and this is how dumb I am I often have
to look at my ID to remember how to
spell it correctly I think you're lying
because you wouldn't just tell me
because they ask you all the time and
you won't tell me no I've told you
before it's really Benjamin it sure is
Thomas Benjamin McMullen that's correct
what and it's his birthday everybody it
was my birthday yesterday damn swinging
a mess happy birthday thank you very
much that's what I was getting the bozos
and homies who hit me up they did all
that no some people did that's how I saw
a comment on YouTube it's Toby's
birthday and I said I knew that so I
pulled out the old phone and sent a text
hey happy birthday to my best 29th of
December talk about [ __ ] coming in
the hard way it stinks
[ __ ] between a rock and a bad holiday I
was given a birthday cake on Christmas
talk about a tough look man split your
cake with Jesus
turned your piece into crumbs uh that
sucks that great did you do it this year
they gave you they gave me the birthday
cake sure because I got a I got a cousin
or a yeah I got a cousin who also has
the same birthday we had a little shared
cake it was very sweet oh what did I
know that I told you before we started
recording oh you did okay wow you share
one man now normally would you he's at
the lunch end dinner normally would you
be together on your birthday and you
have to share a birthday cake with them
no no no no they live in North Carolina
I haven't spent a birthday with his
family and uh I'm saying when he was a
kid whatever No No so at least you kind
of got that Spotlight growing up sure
you just shared it with Jesus yeah my
parents had a birthday tree and a
Christmas tree very embarrassing oh my
God got me in the local newspaper these
Backwoods Hillbillies what are they
doing
the mayor was Apostle
I got you five meetings five minutes
with the with the mayor I'm kidding mom
the birthday tree was great
um since everybody was home and around
their family I got two things to propose
for you what's that pal is it trash if
you keep clean pots and pans
like not you're not cooking with them
you're not cooking they're not dirty if
you leave them on the stove if that's
where they live is that trash they live
there that's bad you think so huh uh
what do you say hillbilly they shouldn't
be out yeah unless they're hanging in a
nice kind of order now on the stove and
they're they live I'll do it I did it
this morning I washed my two little pans
after I made my my brekkie and I put
them right back on the stove because
they were still a little wet or what I
was just kind of was like I'll deal with
that later yeah you figure if you put
them in there mushrooms will grow on
them or something like that I mean
really that's what you worry about
mushrooms growing on your pots and pans
between breakfast and lunch
that's right quick
I don't want moss growing them on my
Skillet
um that was the first thing yeah that is
true they should be away especially if
company's over that'd be one thing if
it's there or whatever you'll get to it
but that's not you can't keep them on
there like it's uh no like it's a
showroom that's first of all it's not a
showroom no and the second also what
showroom do you go where you're like oh
like what would it look like if the pans
were on this stuff Ikea does that don't
they I don't think so no I love those
Ikea showrooms but what makes me think
of what like a different life I would
have you know there's always a family in
the Next Room [ __ ] you know your
dad's got that Mom in a headlock that's
just some stock boy who missed breakfast
keep it moving fatty
go check out the Linens
that and do you have a relative that a
male relative that always misses a
little tiny spot when they're shaving uh
oh yeah not always but I I that was the
first I did notice that on a couple of
uncles
my dad for a while had a little baby
mini Hitler right here that little tiny
one that he always missed that's brutal
there's a certain age you get where you
you miss the neck ah and you get like
four long hairs and you're like you
didn't really well after you shaved you
got to get up I get up real close and I
got the tri-fold mirror I check it from
every angle you give it this you give it
that really because I'm getting to that
I'm kind of in that now what that uh I
got a lot of [ __ ] going on I got I have
I have that's an understatement but sure
I got the ear hair I have the long I
have a long hair on my ear
that just goes and goes and goes and I
forget about it
I mean
okay you forget about it and then all of
a sudden you're like oh [ __ ] and then
boy can pull it out I got that I'm
starting to get the the the facial hair
that's going up towards my eye like I'm
shaving my cheek like a [ __ ]
like a skunk ape
it's brutal and in my in my ear forget
about it God you gotta take care of it
as you get older I know I got to go back
to the girls and get my eyebrows hooked
up too and I'm in serious need of a of a
petty but it's not the toes it's the
feet and they know it when I come in I
give them a 20 before they I didn't
before they start because that's what
alcoholics do
that's how he tip the bartender before
you start drinking hey buddy I'm gonna
eat it quick and I'm gonna need a fast
all right cold and fast let's go nah man
I I let them know because there's a lot
of exfoliating going on in the bottom of
the feet and they break out the cheese
Greener and they [ __ ] shave it all
off
so I gotta go back to get all gussied up
uh oh I had a two thing one thing I
forgot about it this morning I was going
to Tweet it I was making my Eggies I
typically like a little bit of cheese in
my Eggies sure what I mean a little bit
of shredded cheese if you got a slice of
America whatever just remember that I
don't know about you that wasn't that
wasn't a Birthright for me when I was a
kid no I just started doing it recently
man I feel like a goddamn Aristocrat I
think I was like 10 or 11 when she
started putting little pieces of LV that
Velveeta in there uh I didn't do it I
didn't do it but my only option and I I
contemplated it parmesan the shake
parmesan that's okay I don't think it is
Shake parmesan let me tell you something
about that shake well first hold on it's
grated parmigiana animal it's not it's
not any of that it's what are you using
the craft and the green bottle or do you
get the nice you get La catella you get
locketella yeah that's like damn box the
bird don't allow it first of all she'll
buy the fresh she typically buys the
fresh parmesan that's okay yeah that's
okay
we have that thing now too it's a cheese
grater but like it looks like a shovel
and then it just has the little dots in
it where you where I think that's for
fruit is it oh maybe I guess everything
but yeah yeah the little like handle one
it looks like you do your toe you do
your heels with yeah yeah exactly I
think that's yeah you [ __ ] over
anything yeah but I didn't do it but I
was all I was like because just because
it would ruin them and I was out of eggs
it wasn't to ruin them I don't know it
wouldn't have been great I am that's not
true it's also like it's it's it's uh
Parmesan cheese
pecorino Romano hey Jesus Christ is a
family show here
take your pecorino and do whatever you
want with it on your own time Ray
Romano's Italian cousin huh uh I I have
some breakfast news from down south okay
Cindy's guys there's a squirrel this
time of the year
is it flying the Flying Squirrel that's
an Easter are you kidding me uh Cindy's
got your back fully on what she cooks
the whole pack of bacon City go no yeah
that's the problem the problem I didn't
say that I ate it I I clearly said we
died no I watched it you've admitted
that it gets eaten throughout the day
yes
I guarantee you his mom is not eating a
pack of bacon I pay the old man goes in
there and picks
sure yeah listen yeah the the argument
was
you're not a guy who could have just
made bacon laying around and have the
restraint to eat it sure but she said
but you do it in the oven like a
gentleman is what she said okay all
right I don't know give her that
um I'll give her that so I didn't do
that into the cheese but it was one of
those moments of like if this feels like
it's like one step above dog food or
something why that's not you know it's
not first of all it's dude it's just
cheese it's just if you open and find
Forever whatever what's in that nothing
it's aged
dry aged what are you talking about dry
heat it's aged cheese cheese all cheese
is aged yeah they age it a little longer
you don't know what you're talking about
yeah she's Monger over here do you not
put your cheese in the fridge I do I do
but that just sits out on the shelf
forever sure that could sit on the shelf
for years there's an expiration date
it's first of all let me put on the
Shelf they put it in the tube and that
hangs off the shelf the two little like
dispenser oh yeah
I'd like to know what brand that is
because I don't think it would have been
that bad if you okay there's two ways
you could have done that it was more of
like uh I don't wanna I don't you could
have sprinkled that in while you were
cooking it or at the end when you're
done and you put it on your plate you
can hit it with a little bit of that I
know I'm aware and you know it's not a
bad combination this might be an
unpopular uh opinions might be decisive
decisive apartment on this side divisive
divisive
um plug you back in the parmesan cheese
and a little bit of ketchup goes
together pretty well
I don't know I like that parmesan cheese
or anything I love it I sprinkle it on
my salad
I'll give you that yeah I don't know
just it just felt like such a cheap
substitute to like I was looking for
some nice shredded you know something
breadcrumbs would have been a cheap
substance and then to put [ __ ] you
know sawdust all my eggs in the morning
when I'm trying to [ __ ] sit there
like a gentleman that just didn't feel
right
um blue cheese would have been a problem
some crumbled blue cheese I'll turn an
egg around though you'd chop it up I
used to do feta a lot
man when I first found out about feta it
was
uh probably four years four years ago it
was the first time I came a line item in
my monthly expenditure I was buying
fresh feta it's great like cry was
putting it in everything yeah didn't
come across that until I was probably
about 25. yeah fed is [ __ ] fantastic
but blue cheese and eggs I'm joking I do
like crumbled blue cheese of course it's
not an eggs though what's the difference
oh I don't know about that it's not bad
on a burger
um the shelf life of craft parmesan
grated cheese 10 to 12 months in the
refrigerator in the refrigerator what is
it on the Shelf though before you open
it some of that stuff sits there for
like a decade that ain't good I don't
know what other cheese lasts that long
too that don't make any sense the
roaches ever eat that that don't make no
sense no other cheese you'd get last a
year
well we were kids you know Irish Irish
household she bought one of those every
two years I went through it that also
butter noodles
okay we didn't really [ __ ] with it well
we were heavy on it yeah it would it
would it would get it would turn into a
boulder before you have to really give
it the [ __ ] yeah you'd really have to
tap the 57s on that thing
I'll loosen that up a little bit give
that thing a couple of drinks
another thing too obviously Christmas
just passed and then some uh somber news
my stepfather passed away
um so we're down there at the house you
know the whole thing and uh it was a day
or two after uh after Christmas and so I
was down there and I left yesterday I
came back up
to New York yesterday
and I was getting ready to leave the
house uh-huh and you know it's like
Christmas just happened right so there's
like boxes and gifts and the trees
everything's up
so I got my stepdad a 50 gift
certificate to Wawa that's what he likes
that's what it was he would have wanted
me to have the sizzling
so I'm getting ready to leave and that
gift card's just sitting there
and you spend a dead man's Wawa gift
card is what I want to know a 50 gift
card that's where you got him that's all
he wants I might it was a very unique
man my my sister bought him the same
flannel every year my brother bought him
uh something else a button up maybe that
he would wear and then I would get him a
50 gift card I think last year I was
probably a 20 gift card we're being
honest but I've made a couple of bucks
this year so I sprung for the 50.
he deserved it he was a great man
okay is it crazy my mom goes take it
take it it just did it that's her I felt
like I was robbing his grave he's gonna
need it to pay the boat man
two Exxon cards over his eyes that's
terrible
Wawa we're a Wawa family yeah dude that
that's not your mom's you can't take it
she told me that I didn't steal it she
she's in mourning what the [ __ ] poor
woman's in shock
Jesus Christ so if anybody's out there
I'm trying to get there's no Wawas
around here I'm willing to I'm willing
to far away he's with it for a cash
value get an extra large bag of flips
you can't take it with you
uh yeah you're a dirt pack yeah man I
didn't spend it yet and I did go to Wawa
to get said sizzling
my [ __ ] I got a sizzling two diet
iced tea I don't know how they make a
large cup of coffee God damn those
sizzlies are all right
uh oh I had another thing while I was at
said Wawa not using the gift card paying
with my own my own box uh-huh okay let's
talk about that rocket money baby ah
that rocket money saving you money on
your subscriptions because you got a
bunch of subscriptions that you don't
realize you don't have you think you're
spending 20 50 80 bucks a month when
you're getting jacked up about two three
hundred yeah so they do they go through
they cancel all the subscription you're
not using push them a button yeah easy
peasy a double it's uh it's fantastic
you can even find out if you've been
double charged for a subscription what's
happened out there those big
corporations trying to wet their beak
without once or twice double dipping on
you oh we didn't know blah blah blah to
cancel subscriptions you just press
cancel rocket money takes care of the
rest easy peasy baby I did it I found
out I was paying for uh some some bogus
[ __ ] streaming site were you yeah
something I signed up for a free trial
and then they were just taking out like
14 bucks a month every time sons of
[ __ ] so you get rid of useless
subscriptions with rocket money now go
to rocketmoney.com garbage seriously it
could save you hundreds of dollars per
year that's rocketmoney.com garbage
cancel your unnecessary subscriptions
right now at rocketmoney.com garbage do
it okay let's talk about true Classics
oh baby love that true class let's talk
about the most comfortable best fit and
t-shirt out there that's in the bed and
big boys here's the Scoop everyone's
been giving me [ __ ] saying I'm a 5x I
squeeze into there and it feels really
good I wear it as my undershirt to keep
me warm in the winter and let me tell
you when I lose the weight I'll be a
true Classics man through and through
pipes feel good that does belly doesn't
show it's all I wear baby comfy cozy
I've been a true classic man beef way
before they even started advertising on
a podcast that's how much I love it and
you gotta cycle new ones in you've worn
the hell out of your shirts get them in
I order a couple like every every two
months I get a pack come in and keep it
fresh you look good they feel good your
first step to feeling Good's looking
good baby stop being a dirtbag what do
you do with your life uh you can get 25
off at trueclassic.com garbage for free
shipping included on purchases over a
hundred dollars at 25 off at
trueclassic.com garbage uh Santa won't
be the only one slaying this time of
year thanks to True Classics I put one
on and my wife wants to have sex with me
it's great 25 off at trueclassics.com
such garbage do it I saw maybe one of
the toughest looks that I've seen
because I was there okay I've been I've
I've done something very similar I've
done it but the guy in front of me
buying a couple two tree things probably
you know was like 35 bucks I think he
had like a pack of smokes you know he
had a couple of sandwiches whatever
looks like he was like getting stuff for
like the office or whatever sure I mean
a group of people with a family or
whatever
and he uh they cater now too by the way
Wawa does I'm getting divorced and I'm
getting married again just to have them
do that
um
they uh so
his card gets declined guy in front of
you guy in front of me not judging you
know I've been there been there like I
don't know their computers were down
um something that's what you say she
goes no it doesn't go through so now
you're thinking
do I jump in it's the holidays do I help
them out really
gift card on me
um no I'm just sitting there waiting I'm
like whatever it's just awkward because
it's like it's taking a while and he
goes I don't know let me try again I'm
like Buddy save yourself don't do it
again we know it ain't going through you
do the same card twice then you go to
the LIE let me try another card oh [ __ ]
I don't have it on me then you throw
coffee in their face your grandma ain't
gonna make a move for the safe
[Music]
douse him in orange drink to run for the
door and stop sticky be getting that out
of their hair for weeks and you duck
down because I got the tape measure
they're looking for some [ __ ] who's
five three
um
no so he
typically that's a shame that is usually
a shameful process for the person in it
right you're like I'm sorry that's a
shameful process for the Dirtbag who
doesn't have money that's why we have
always had shame in it because we were
always lying knowing full well that it
was probably gonna get declined or it
was a 50 50 shot people who have
you know back up credit cards and you
know all that kind of stuff they're they
just they know that it's an electronic
issue it does this I wasn't getting
electronic issue vibes from this guy
this guy was hemmed up it seemed him you
straighten them out no
merry Christmas everybody this is the
season hey buddy I got a haunted gift
card
oh man
yikes um but so what he did was he goes
oh this is [ __ ] pulls out the
banking app on his phone uh-huh and he
goes look I got money and I'm like
there's that's a bad that's a guy who
knows he's wrong first of all I think
that was a screenshot yeah a screenshot
someone else you Googled Chase Banking
that picture no you had money in July of
2021. so that's an old statement
ah this poor bastard so what'd you do he
then started moving some suit at one
point he's on his phone and just not
even worried about the line or oh hold
on take him let me you know I gotta
transfer he's on the phone who's he
talking to
nobody's talking to the person what
person the cashier oh he's showing them
like the banking she's like what the
[ __ ] sir I don't care gotcha
not at one point does he go oh stop oh
I'm sorry here take him whatever you
know now my sizzling is getting cold got
breakfast to eat I'm gonna put this back
in the heat lamp hey buddy he looks like
he's gonna be a while I'm gonna get this
back under the light okay
um
dude at one point he's got venmo open
he's got he's just looking for like
couch change at this point to make this
person they finally made it but it took
about
two minutes okay you're just sitting
that's too long I feel you step aside
hey I'm sorry hold on just give me a
second
if you got me behind you and you step
aside
I'm taking care of that for you
if it's reasonable I'm not dropping two
G's in a while three cartons of [ __ ]
phone moles of this guy
stop buying Bernies for them boys yeah
yeah you're not getting a pallet
lunchbox
because that shows a little humility you
know what I mean yeah yeah I got a
question for you fellas hold on one
second speaking of Wawa shout out to
Chris at The Flower Town Wawa
kid works there okay so I'm the other
day with my cousin yeah back here with
that sizzly fat
you didn't pay for that said he loves to
show him and his brothers shout out to
him shout out Chris great to meet you
buddy also another Dirtbag move
performed by Kevin James Ryan
um oh first I want to give a shout out
to uh Mike at suplex sneakers down here
of course
um I hit him up for shoes for the boys
the kids though my nephews
uh which is crazy because kids love
shoes now to get shoes as a kid you were
like give me a toy give me a gun give me
something you know yeah my nephew's the
same way they like the shoes
so I go yo he goes I gotta need these in
a four one on the knees and an eight or
whatever hits me up because y'all send
them to the crib no problem cool about a
bit I go what do I he goes nothing hmm
shout out to him but now I'm giving free
gum giving [ __ ] I got for free as a gift
man talking about a slime I know that
and the 50 gift card I made a pretty
good this year dude
hahaha
I'm up baby I'm up baby
yeah it felt real slime I had to tell
that I had to tell my brother and I said
I told him I got and I I'll get them
something else but I just can't I can't
walk around like I paid for these man if
it comes out in the future I'm really
[ __ ] I think I could have I could have
handled that what do you mean I would I
I would have been okay with that
with what letting let them think that I
paid for them oh for sure but big shout
outs obviously
I don't know it just didn't feel right I
was like let me give you something so I
don't feel like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
foreign
what are your thoughts on a shorty I got
I got a Wawa style question for you
fellas fire away T-Bone have you ever
left a penny take a penny leave a penny
always yeah leave pennies
uh yeah I was always real nervous with
the give a penny leave a penny because
my math was never that I always felt
like my math was all my dad used to do
that and would [ __ ] cashiers up that
started in the 90s right
I believe it did
um they didn't do that [ __ ] in the 80s
my real dad would do like the uh hey
it's five yeah your total is 5 37. and
he would give a penny take a dollar no
he he would hand them like 13 12 and be
like you know what after wait say it
again they would be like hey your total
is 557. okay and then he would not want
all the ones in the change so he would
be like he would give them like 11 and
I'm making this up because I don't know
the math but like 72 cents I'm like just
give me 10.50 back uh you know what I
mean it's like a 13 year old cashier and
he's already like entered so he's now
got to do the math and the rest of the
Wawa line is jammed up doing straight
and then like he like you know here you
owe me two bucks yo it was like he might
have been calling him I don't know well
some meth head with an abacus
uh that is um
uh that usually is a red flag what to
you know just from me working you know
behind a register that's a red food
somebody comes in obviously your dad
wasn't doing that but when somebody
comes in and starts doing the you know
the three con give me this uh this back
and bump up on this 20. you know you're
getting no it was always it was always a
move because it was like I don't want
the seven pennies and the you know it
was like sure just give me
or like and like the ones or whatever
sure just give me a five back I'll give
you an extra dollar instead of giving me
four give me a full five back sure that
and whatever whenever somebody tries to
pay something really small with a large
bill you know you know it's a fake bill
I had one fake Bill one time I got back
from a golf course or like a driving
range I broke a hundred I think they
give me a 20. yeah and it looked wonky
and I took it somewhere and they were
like no I'm like really like I took it
to my I went to a Burger King to be
honest with I got shut down from a
Burger King with it did you know it was
fake I didn't it looked wonky and she's
like sir we can't take this
this is not the king's currency
this must be from a four-way land this
is an outrage
the king is expecting me you realize
that you realize you're holding me up
you knew Marcus Aurelius now I'll take
my burger bunnies
the Burger King Original Chicken
Sandwich the long one
yeah they turn that into a palm probably
around 2001. I was all around Italian or
something bro my brother wheat dude they
were so [ __ ] good the chicken Pond
the long one then they start getting
that [ __ ] trying to compete with
Popeyes and whatever okay you know you
know that rock and roll [ __ ] you [ __ ]
keep it old school baby still you got
the
long dinger
he got the hog
he had chopped up chicken meat but what
the [ __ ] a chicken Patty's great man
they're pulling that was really no if
there's been a parm-made I've had it all
right that was really something I won
yesterday
hold on what what were you saying oh yes
all right so you're trying to pass fake
fake money in Burger King I'm not trying
I had suspected it and I was it was but
you still tried to use it I mean to wet
your whistle I didn't point it out or
anything it was given to me as chains so
you're pushing it off I'm gonna be out
there that's a big Corporation they
account for that every year it's a
write-off they probably threw that kid
in the moat with the alligators at the
end of his shift
Off With His Head
that's victims of my kingdom that's bad
debt
that kid had a paper
[ __ ] that little twerp didn't take it an
embarrassed me in front of my friends
see how embarrassing that was
I gotta watch my friend eat a chicken
parm and not me
also what a wild day went to a driving
range and then Burger King talk about a
couple of studs
Glenn shank the bucket of balls then you
know eight 14 000 calories at lunch
especially gets fit through the door
with all that [ __ ] hanging off you huh
okay probably pulling at you
we walked in there like these guys have
fake money for sure
I pulled up in the Illumina too he
walked in smells like chicken fries
these guys stink
oh man so I went I had to go to like two
or three places and I finally got I
finally got a deli to take you four
bastards should have had the marker you
know what I mean
oh what a scumbag what do you mean I'm
not a scumbag
chasing the dragon chasing the chicken
look if you're gonna take a yellow 20
that's on you
oh man
we're the president
you don't remember that impeachment
hearing you kidding me
I remember I worked uh when I was
working downtown uh
uh the [ __ ] came in trying to get like a
coffee with a hundred and I was like get
the [ __ ] you're saying took one look at
that thing hit it with the pen was like
nah this is no good oh yeah I never care
I never cared enough
um
small business I worked for small
business is a little different obviously
yeah yeah
um like a jam of my boss so you can have
someone pass that off you know you pass
that off somewhere else but we got to
get into some [ __ ] questions baby
this is a goddamn uh family yep I do
remember hold on sorry that I we I
started a war with the Rite Aid in
Astoria
because we uh this is going back this is
I don't know four years ago okay they
got rid of the king-size Snickers and I
wouldn't stand for it they split them up
into two what are we doing
um
uh
uh I had money Western Union to me
you want to talk about low I remember I
didn't know what that was and then when
I was working it acne I thought a couple
of cowboys I know well Western it sounds
like it was it was at that point back in
the at one point yeah back in the day
that's how you communicating get a
Western Union telegram but you had like
called money it didn't make any sense
yeah everybody's IDs were always expired
Western Union there's no way you have a
valid driver's license I've I've done it
I've I've I've had fired it's in someone
else's you got to put it in someone
else's name I've had to do them oh yeah
dude I'm putting in my girl's name and
she doesn't have her license yeah man
I'm talking about a trail of dirt
baggery
um but you get it from the you get it
from the register there yeah and they
they gave us a fake hundred in it
and we went back to try to fight it we
went back multiple times to try and
fight it because I needed that sure
[ __ ] wild they never did we still go
there too like idiots hey get them right
he's got their hooks in here
that's how they got you uh try to get
you but it is a family episode so we'll
answer your questions from the patreon
when you sign up for the patreon we will
answer your garbage question on the air
it's just the best way to do we get a
lot of submissions from other ways
Instagram DMS emails all nine yards but
patreon gets the first crack at it
uh and while we're doing a little
plug-in check out that live stream if
you buy today if you buy before
the first you'll save the save a couple
of bucks you know what I mean so do that
wet your whistle wet your bean you know
um all right let's see this one is
speaking of which I had a little sip of
Yoo-hoo yesterday uh-huh oh yeah we're
doing drinks can't wait to get that I
might get that man that drink was we did
we had that that drink was [ __ ]
awesome the milk with dinner we did
Kahlua shout out to Brooklyn comedy
shout out to Brooklyn Comedy Club head
over there he said he concocted it yeah
it's Yoo-hoo Kahlua and vodka pretty
good on the Rocks I think yeah it was
delicious
great spot over there too to check out a
show
um
all right this one's from Luke 10
shareholder first time question is it
garbage if your sister and your aunt get
into a fist fight at your grandma's wake
right in front of the open coffin until
the point that the funeral home workers
had to split them up and kick the whole
family out let me know thanks
what's the next one
sister and who
sister and Aunt sister and aunt that's a
tough one
um cousins or brother and sister I'll
allow just because that's like a sister
and an aunt whether like how long have
you had been beefing you know what I
mean yeah you're fighting an ant that's
a tough look for your niece that's a
tough look yeah although they want to
strangle my nephew a couple of days ago
but I love him he's a good kid
uh yeah that's tough but hey it's an
emotionally charged event you know what
I mean the passing of a loved one yeah I
can see how you're in front of the
coffin probably boozing a little bit
sure wait what if the viewing you're not
boozing at the viewing
what there's no open bar at the viewing
yeah you could take some nips you got
something cooking no okay you're talking
about you wait that's you do the
luncheon that's when that's when you're
tired oh I've definitely drank pre
funerals and viewings really yeah wow
I'm mourning people
yeah you gotta get after a little bit
it's all black in a Solo Cup yeah
shades on backwards
um all right let's see here this one's
from Mr Neptune 2022. okay dollar
investor here never had a question to
ask is it garbage to always have a pot
of coffee going
also
what are your thoughts on reheating cold
coffee that's been sitting in the pot
for an unknown amount of time did the
day I'm assuming the day yeah they're
having a cup of coffee that's like
thank you
that's like fireman [ __ ] that's like you
know what I mean that's like yeah if
you're not if your job doesn't require
it it's pretty trashy but I'll tell you
this you know it's a pretty good cup of
coffee
wherever you get your muffler or your
[ __ ] oil change your Styrofoam cup
with a little and if they have a little
table that looks like if you touch it
it's gonna everything's gonna fall over
and shatter it's usually not it's
usually like an end table from a living
room too it's never like for that purp
it's always repurposed powdered
non-dairy creamer white sugar and one of
those old Mr Coffee coffee pots no lid
no dude hair the man the spores get to
it dude you put that there with one of
them straws where you're chewing a piece
of gum
we start talking shop real quick yeah I
got a nudie calendar hanging on the wall
getting it done right that's a cup of
coffee right there huh that's all right
I don't mind that [ __ ] gang the show is
sponsored by better help this time of
year when you really go nuts you need
someone to talk to someone to talk to
you talk you down I get it I'm a crazy
guy myself you're thinking about losing
it
talk to Better Health
back and talk to better how hey man it's
the winter what do they call it seasonal
this seasonal depression after the
holidays it's tough It's a tough time of
year it really shows the cracks there's
a lot of stress a lot of pressure
financially at work the deadlines of
this to that dealing with the family the
whole nine yards I get it baby therapy
is very important talk therapy is a
fantastic tool to have and with better
help they make it very easy therapy
option that's convenient flexible
affordable entirely online you fill out
a brief questionnaire uh you get matched
with a licensed therapist and switch
therapist at any time no additional
charge easy peasy lemon squeezy if you
want to live a more empowered life
therapy can get you there baby take it
grab Life by the Bulls do it yeah visit
betterhelp.com garbage today get 10 off
your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com garbage one more time that's
betterhelp help help.com garbage do it
keep it Saturday's time baby listen up
you perverts
calling all freaks and Weirdos attention
attention pull your pants down let's
party gang you like having sex you like
getting weird in the bedroom you like
sticking things up your ass that came in
the mail
sure we all do uh-huh do yourself a
favor get over there to Adam and Eve and
what do they got cooking right now I
think it's almost anything on the sites
50 off our listeners get 50 off almost
anything I don't just use coach garma to
check out and you'll get 50 off plus
free shipping that's 50 off an
adventurous new toy yeah a slippery Lube
or almost anything else you desire I'm
so glad that we're now in the age where
that's all you know nothing's taboo
anymore you do whatever you want you
enjoy yourself I know in the privacy of
your own home yeah and the coolest thing
is they send the discreet package of
course it doesn't show up saying
boners.net shove it my wife likes it
weird.org that's what I would want yeah
people people in two are getting loose
you open it up in the lobby and he gets
a blow up doll but the boys know what I
can handle uh seriously guys all jokes
aside it's a fantastic website so go to
adamandeve.com select any one item that
you want to put in your butt and use
code garbage that's
adamandeve.com put something in you put
your wiener in something put something
in you use code garbage adamandeve.com
now back to the show back to the show
yeah
um I don't think uh the pot of coffee on
all day I kind of think that's classy
to be honest with you no I don't know no
a cappuccino machine is classy yeah do
you want an espresso I gotta I gotta we
got the espresso machine or whatever get
out of here with that [ __ ] nice a
nice pot of coffee on all day and on a
cold day when you're working
that's pretty good I'm just sit in your
house watching TV and you got coffee
going you're not expecting company
that's like psychopath [ __ ] let's just
stay up and watch the neighbors that's
real weird Patty keeps it going until
about noon you get a hot cup of coffee
over at the Foley so about one o'clock
in the afternoon you want Denise moved
to the [ __ ] Keurig which I respect
because when I'm there I don't like them
I don't love them it's not my favorite
cup of coffee but it's instant it's
right away I know but it's right away
I got a cup of coffee I'm not doing it
every day when I'm there want a cup of
coffee you got coffee in [ __ ] 90
seconds ain't nothing better than that
but every that thing is empty every time
I go over I'm the guy who [ __ ] fills
the water oh [ __ ] what are you doing
here yeah get this thing hardwired piped
in my Aunt Mary Catherine and Uncle red
used to have Tasters Choice which was
freeze-dried the crystals instant no
that's Folgers this was instant coffee I
never got I never we never [ __ ] with
that dude it would do that with a bunch
of sugar and some cream it's so good
good there's probably
seven thousand milligrams of caffeine in
that [ __ ] yeah it's [ __ ] talk about
Nitro dude it's a rocket fuel I remember
having that when I was a kid that'd give
me a little bit what was it what was the
cup of coffee brand you had cooking at
the crib what'd Patty get uh and I
assume it was was it the big was it the
metal container or she do the bag the
fresh ground bag at the supermarket it
was in the freezer I know that yeah it
was always in the freezer
um along with the jewelry
cut that
um
do you remember when the freeze-dried
things came out to Bricks yeah yeah it
was that he didn't then keep it in there
once it was open yeah she did she kept
it in there and folded it down razor
burnt coffee dude that's cool that's a
wild combo chock full of nuts was big
over at the house I never knew what that
was and I saw it it seemed so sexual to
me chock full of nuts that's [ __ ] full
of nuts is right there
that was too I thought that was like a
bit I thought that was cough coffee that
Spencer's Gift salt or something hey
keep your gang bang juice out of my ass
your erotic greeting cards are you
[ __ ] perverts this looks like coffee
and they would have in a movie chocolate
yeah like where it just says they're
drinking beer and it just says beer on
the side I think that's a big brand it
is it was yeah yeah yeah yeah no it was
uh well she always had to have two she
had to have decaf for the old man uh-huh
because at a certain point he couldn't
do caffeine anymore when he was young he
started having uh panic attacks and
stuff like that not panic attacks but he
was having like anxiety attacks of the
caffeine because my dad sounds familiar
he would roll that that's why I lay off
there I lay off the coffee a little bit
he would roll down
uh for work and he would pour a cup of
coffee he would do maybe three quarters
of a cup of coffee then finish the rest
of it with cold water and just boom boom
do that twice
and then [ __ ] out the door
gonna come home at [ __ ] five o'clock
breathe into a paper bag talk about red
lines
throw it into second relax if two kids
to look after
um
so he had theater switched to decaf
which I believe was Folgers it was
Folgers in the green thing that's always
how I feel yeah yeah stay away from that
real [ __ ] give me a blue why would you
rock with uh mom was typically Folgers
or that eight o'clock
it was the red bag you would get the
beans and then at the Super Fresh they
would grind them what what you did that
I didn't I'm just saying your mom did
that your mom was doing fresh beans
getting them fresh grounded my mom did
that once she thought it was a scam I
know they did it they grounded for free
and I love this I love the smell oh dude
I would go over and play with it as a
kid the place that I worked downtown we
used to we fresh ground the coffee and
that was one of the things of side work
you would do you get out of the basement
with [ __ ] I can't remember the beans
dude it smelled it made you want coffee
so much that's when I had bad anxiety
because I had that thirty thousand
dollar espresso machine behind me and I
would just [ __ ] Crush double
espressos cappuccinos and all that [ __ ]
all day yeah walk out of there thinking
the cops are looking for me yeah she did
so she would do that
you were doing the [ __ ] grinding the
beans at the grocery but this bra would
forget that was supposed to just bring
the beans back so like she'd throw a
couple in your mouth you had to like go
back to be like yeah if you know just go
you run in and ask them to you know I
don't think we're bringing outside Goods
in
hey man I got beans can you grind them
for me
it was a tough look I remember being
like I'm not going in there I'm not
asking the guy this is your mistake
huh what a piece of [ __ ]
yeah that we stayed away from that that
was that was fancy [ __ ] getting the
beans ground there yeah because the
supermarket stepped it up a little bit
it was but it was free it was free it
doesn't matter it's something yeah
because that's when they started doing
the the artisanal coffee beans that were
in like the little shoots you'd put them
into your little coffee bag we didn't do
that
sealed
bags yeah yeah it was like you would buy
a ground it would just be in the beans
and then they would open it and dump it
in
like an old Chevy tournament fresh cup
of coffee right there
not bad
um that's a good cue all right this
one's from Samantha also 10 homie here
is it garbage to use a family member's
address for a child to attend a school
that's not in town because I
because the the actual town the child
lives in has shitty schools South State
Champions are one I don't know yeah uh
although it is a little it's wonky oh
that's trashy of course but you're doing
the best for the kid typically of course
but we I had a buddy that was that kid I
had two buddies that were that kid
actually and the one was using it to go
here the other one was using to go there
they were using each other's address to
go to the school they weren't going sure
which is always like where the mail gets
sent and stuff it's like real
it's a really popular for that too
tax dollars at work sure
yeah but we had a pretty good school
district so people would do it all the
time and like you know like I'm getting
you know taking the [ __ ] city bus up
or something
bad look
yeah that's [ __ ] I like that that's
how [ __ ] that's a state champs are
[ __ ] boring right there bringing the
kids in all right this one's from Ronnie
McElroy is it garbage to try to disguise
your Heist your high dollar purchases
example making a purchase in a jeweler
store but putting it in a bag from Foot
Locker or breaking up the box your flat
screen came in so the neighborhood
doesn't know you got a new TV at
Christmas always do that you never you
never put the box out that's a rest in
peace that's a Chris cotton
100 joke you cut it out he cut the Box
up a little bit and put it out a few
days at a time so no one knows you got
fresh [ __ ] gear yeah absolutely like
Shawshank when he's getting rid of the
dirt yeah yeah you gotta you got a
[ __ ] Panasonic box falling out of
your legs yeah you never just slap a
[ __ ] 72-inch [ __ ] uh Samsung box
out front no you might as well put a
bullseye on the house yeah uh I don't
know I never we never really [ __ ]
thought of that I think of that [ __ ] now
that I'm I mean maybe my parents are
known I don't remember
we also my dad just got rid of the trash
he just took all the trash to the office
he was real weird about trash that would
go find dumpsters to put stuff in I get
caught every morning behind a bag I got
caught
like stop making me do it I [ __ ]
hated it we go to this Bank off Street
Road like the house trash like coffee
grounds yeah he didn't like it at the
crib what do you mean you're a crazy guy
he just was like I don't know he didn't
have the trash cans outside we would
but he would take it with him you'd get
caught little fat kid getting out of the
car yes I got caught a bunch I'd have to
take like I remember the one time I mean
at this point I was driving I was
probably like 17 I was driving like a
work truck oh he would make you do it
himself okay he would go with him and
he'd go hop out and I'd have to Pop the
trunk and [ __ ]
felt like you're doing a bank job dude
also who knows if something went down he
might have [ __ ] peeled out and left
me there too yeah I mean that's every
man for himself when the fuzz he runs up
and grabs you by the shirt I got the
little [ __ ] officer citizens arrest
caught this kid throwing my trash away
man yeah what would the bank manager say
no it wasn't the manager it was like I
think the cops all the tree rode the
cops but I'll be like you know there's
no dumping in here and we're like
you know
why don't you go crack another case all
right this case is closed
oh man that's a tough one you're getting
busted by the cops for dumping I got
caught by I was getting rid of furniture
or something not Furniture but like no
it was trash it was like contractor bags
and I was throwing in a dumpster off
bustle to like down like some like in
Northeast somewhere
and uh I got caught the guy goes yo no
dump it in there I was like all right my
bad I had to like pull it out and put it
back in sure it came and was like oh any
of that yours some of it was I guess did
you ever have this if somebody a family
a family friend if anybody
was getting something done at the house
and there was a dumpster
yeah that would be open season
they we would alert each other hey just
so you know we have the dumpster in the
driveway if you're trying to get rid of
anything bring it over ah when they come
for miles to be like Field of Dreams
[ __ ] a bunch of dirtbags coming out
coming out of the corner dude I'm
telling you I got an old bike it's a
bunch of Brown Christmas trees
old bike sewing machines washing washer
dryers all that [ __ ] dude we had a
dumpster in our driveway I'm not even at
my dad's house I'm not even [ __ ]
around for
two years they're good to have two years
oh she's doing work in a house I never
really started though so it was just
like trash and stuff first thing you do
is get the dumpster yeah drop the
dumpster yeah and it dropped I said I
won't put the dumpster coming we gotta
come get this like it's you haven't you
know it's not just like a full yet yeah
that was bad I used to work for a
landscaping guy this old Irish guy and
he would uh we'd go into a yard I swear
to God uh-huh go into a backyard
cut down some trees do this do that and
if they were up against
any type of wooded area just over this
over the side over the side yeah a lot
of respect I got caught a couple of
times he put me in a couple bad
situations doing that because we're in
like a pretty nice neighborhood and I
just can't just throw it over I'm like
there's people there's people like
barbecue whatever they're pulling [ __ ]
yeah lady came up started screaming at
me this guy's deer thumping oh my God
now we're gonna get it we just do it to
put it over here it's just it's a joke
I'm playing a prank on him you shut up
we'll take care of it you're gonna watch
MTV do you
um uh all right let's see this one's
from tennillo shout out to uh the
canelo's up there
one at a restaurant and the waiter asks
you a question and your mouth is full do
you answer the question or do you wait
till you're done chewing
that's a pretty refined question I gotta
give you that canelo's a real Dirtbag
I'll always give your own grape I guess
they know as yours or you were a waiter
I guess you would you're assumed that
if people are sitting there I would
ambush people all the time and they
would look at me
you gonna finish that
um because those are the steps of
service you want to check back like
after the first two minutes to make sure
everything's good if I I'd catch
everybody mid bite but it should also
just be a yes or no question so you can
give a nod of like is everything okay
and you go you know what I mean like
yeah I'll do that like us oh yeah of
course if I got a mouthful of [ __ ]
you know prosciutto or whatever I give
them the A-Okay or thumbs up like this
is a good one yeah but you can't be like
hey what'd you do today you know what I
mean it's got to be a yes or no question
the hand over the mouth while you're
talking is no good either that's no good
but it's polite it's you're you're in a
bad spot you know what I mean it's not
like you're telling a story of like so
the other day I was walking down the
street you're answering a question
because but I ate over a kid's house
once when I was younger and the family
didn't talk while they were eating but
most of the mom and the dad and they
would kind of like reprimand you not
reprimand you but like when the food hit
the table and they were eating
I I like so I was like chit chatting
with the old man I'm like hey catch that
Philly's game and the mom was like we we
we refrain from from talking why why
we're eating it's better for digestion
I was like well I'll take my dinner back
in America take a good look around his
place he ain't gonna be seeing my fat
ass in here anymore I like to chit chat
you know what I mean yeah yeah yeah of
course crazy were you a TV on oh yeah at
the at the table was on the TV was on in
the other room or like or I guess TV
you're set up now the kitchen table TV
would be on in the living room
uh uh kinda during the week yeah Action
News would be on so Patty can see what
Jim Gardner was yapping about uh-huh
what he was wearing yeah what he was
doing they want to know what's going on
what's going on with felly
um but I remember being a little kid
in our house in Mountaintop and we had a
little TV muffin top because we had a
Muffin Top PA I remember sitting at the
kitchen table we had a little TV
watching MASH while I ate and I was like
oh this is clean living my friend had
the little like nine at nine inch or
whatever in the kitchen the TV like it
was like mounted under the thing I
thought that was like we were in like a
NASA [ __ ] TV in the kitchen is about
as cozy as it gets
um
we would have it on because like where
you know where we interviewed Denise
sure that table
and you could see into the living oh
yeah yeah we would have it on it
sometimes when she was like fed up she's
like turn it off like go turn the TV off
but if there was you know it was on a
good chunk unless it was like a
everybody sit down and we're you know
yeah even watching TV that's [ __ ] As
Good As It Gets I don't hate it baby no
it's all right I hate it it's all right
um all right let's see this one's just
funny this is from Nick is a garbage is
sit in the back seat of your own car
hahaha
you're pretty jammed up if you're in the
back seat you're [ __ ] you're drunk
yeah you're in a bag see you're drunk
which I have been and it's strange but
that could be a rich guy thing
I don't think that's what Nick meant
Nick was Nick gets blackout drunk and
then gets in the back of his Corolla
he's not he's not getting driven in his
Phantom
okay nice try nice save but come on yeah
if you're in the back of a Nissan going
a lot of leg room back here yeah it's
just bigger than I thought you're drunk
you just puked on yourself you're asking
her to stop at Wendy's
come on
that's good
um all right let's see here
this is from Ryman Hoffer 20 shareholder
yeah shout out to it is a garbage gonna
make change in the church collection
basket had the break of 20.
listen I'm not a man of the Lord anymore
I don't know is there a thing to like if
you do drop the you do I don't know what
are you giving 10 maybe it's listen it's
[ __ ] trash sure to do that it's not
even that it's a matter of you go hey
get back working with the 20 pal it's a
matter of timing that they they're
[ __ ] moving so for for the
non-catholics out there when heathens
I'm seeing hell
living in the back of my key let's go
be the devil worshipers out there uh
when right before right before they they
do communion which which is like a
little greater yeah they they hit you up
for a little scratch you know what I
mean you got bills to pay so they they
got they got these old cases to cover
hey movement fees ain't cheap yeah so
they have these old father O'Malley had
to get sent to eight different states
last month they have these old schoolers
come around usually a nice blue blazer
and a pair of [ __ ] uh gray gray cat
gray chinos as they called them tons of
cologne old guys in a church they come
around a [ __ ] you know a little
something for the effort yeah
but it's a you they got to keep it
moving take a percent of that do they
get 10 if they upsell you yeah
but I have seen them whacking it up in
the back of the church that was fun they
put in a bag I put in like a you know
like a potato sack dude they were like
they were like Casino guys that's when
you started putting it all together
you're like oh [ __ ] they're in the back
there it's sitting in
uh the church the church that we grew up
going to was attached to a school
obviously so they're sitting in like one
of those little seats like for like a
first screen or at like a like a little
you know communal desk [ __ ] just
whacking up [ __ ] 20s like Casino
um but they got to keep it moving they
got tired make change they've got time
to be dealing with that [ __ ] I know my
thing is yes it's a tough look but I do
get it if you're like I give 10 or
whatever then I would I would just put
the 20 in and then just not give the
next week sure be like I got you a wish
wash or whatever or here's a dub I'm
good for the month if you're doing
survivors sure but they don't put the
screw seeing that much anymore either
they do it they do it real quick dude in
the 80s they would stop right in front
of you like let's go dude we were
somewhere they'd hit you with it
put your finger out of your ass let's go
uh
uh they were somewhere and they they
were somewhere at my chair like the
church we grew up going to but I was
older I think they were doing like an
addition or something they were putting
like a new gym on or something they ran
it back they did two collections I
remember my dad going he's [ __ ]
like right away he's like these greedy
bastards running the balls to run it
back and that one was quick man nobody
was reaching for their dude they would
just get to that nope okay nope all
right nope people were [ __ ] before
even got there people give them the
[ __ ] wave off like keep it moving
back [ __ ] Jim's leaking yeah
that's good
um all right let's do one morning we got
a wrap her up here uh this one's from
Robert Redford's penis oh no that's his
government name all right new ten dollar
homie here never had a question red are
you garbage if you had to sleep in a
tent inside of your grandfather's house
because it was so dirty
that's [ __ ] nut wild that's like
hoarder [ __ ] that's what I picture like
cat dead cats or cat dude hoarders
[ __ ] makes my skin girl I can smell
those houses I remember I was going door
to door selling whatever the [ __ ] I was
always a dead cat squished between some
newspaper somewhere uh-huh and I
remember I this they owe this family
opened up the hat like the door they
were like hoarders like you know that's
like also like tends to be somewhat of a
crazy was that around back in the day or
is that a newer thing I was oh yeah I
think it's always been around I think it
just recently had a name to it huh okay
or like became more of a understand un
understood thing okay but this family
man you opened it up and it was like
floor to ceiling the family yeah it was
a kid
newspapers [ __ ] those sleepovers
there oh probably a couple of kids that
got lost like [ __ ] Everest they're
Frozen They're Frozen behind the shoe
boxes the old Anderson boy
went into 303 it never hurt was heard of
again yikes but he was like he was
wanted to just talk to me or like maybe
he thought he could get something for
free or wanted the papers or something
wait so tell me this is going door to
door selling like Windows Roofing and
Siding oh okay and I got to him and he's
like oh he was like this made his month
to like talk to me it's probably a waft
came out of that door I was like dry
even talking to him and I'm like dude
first of all there's no way she just got
out of Chili's you got a southwest
chicken salad
again got a bad sweater vest on too I'm
sitting there like a bozo had a jacket
with a lift ticket on it
looking like a [ __ ] [ __ ] and this
guy was just jerking me around I
wouldn't be like I think I walked away
finally buddy listen you ain't got that
you ain't got the disposable income or
the care to put in for the room
he just wanted the windows just to have
enough just Pile in the trash oh man did
you hit get that a lot what just because
it was mostly get off my [ __ ] yard
sure but did you get it you get did you
get a few sad people who just wanted
somebody to talk to for a little while
well the lie was you would go we're
doing some work in the neighbor we're
doing work on one of your users now he
didn't drug you and eat your fat ass I
know I'll always step back a little bit
there was tactics to canvassing couldn't
even step back from the store yeah so no
so you're not it's a sales tax so you're
not threatening them
you're not like right up on the door
like hey what are you doing in there and
also it also lets them open the door
because if you're there they won't open
the door nothing's scarier than somebody
knocking on your screen door by the way
and [ __ ] rattles the whole house if you
want to get the foleys in an uproar
[ __ ] bang on the screen door I sucked
man pop up like prairie dogs I had to be
selling people would get so mad and
you'd see them in there and they're like
I know you're [ __ ] I can see in there
Walter let's go get out of here so I can
rip you off yeah get out of here and
I'll charge you 50 grand for a roof
yeah it's good stuff but we gotta wrap
her up gang gang we love you see you at
the live stream see at the live stream
today see if we save a two three bucks
you know what I mean something you're
all free with the boys let's do it we
love you gang we'll see you next week
peace